Cool, okay, task one, could you verify the functionality of adding a new recurring expense
and splitting it amongst all of the household members?
Make sure you speak out loud.
Okay, so, is it add expense button at the bottom right, so I'm just going to go with
that.
I'm just going to add a name, it seems like it's compulsory, so I'm just going to fill
out the rest of the things we're all with.
I can't type it, but it's, does that fill something in for me, which it works, because
I don't want to type anyway.
I'm going to select rent, because it said it was rent, and I'll enter an amount.
I can't enter an amount?
Oh, it gave me an amount, fantastic.
That's really expensive.
I'm glad my rent isn't that much.
Alright, let me add a date.
I think it will add one for me again.
Yep, it did, fantastic.
And I want to make it recurring, so I'm going to select a value, and rent, for that much
rent, you should be paying it every month, so I'm going to go monthly, and I want to
split it equally with all flatmates, right?
So I'll select everybody, me, Alex, and Sam.
I'll add a description, I guess I'll let it add it for me, right for the three of us,
love it.
I'll press the create button at the bottom.
I'm just not letting it press it.
Okay.
It's not letting it press it.
Yeah, I believe that might be an issue with the app, so we can just continue from there.
That's all good.
Make note of that.
Cool, okay, task two.
Could you ensure the functionality of paying an existing expense, and verify that it's
removed?
Okay.
So, you're wanting to pay an amount that you're owing to somebody.
So, I've got my upcoming, so I don't think I'm talking about that.
I think I'm going to pay someone who I owe money to, so I'll try pay Alex for rent,
not, I'm trying to click on, so I initially tried to click on the user name of the person,
it doesn't work, so I've pressed the pay button instead.
And now I've got all my list of things I need to pay, which is great.
So I'm going to pay rent, and then I'll press the pay button.
It's less than big, which is cool.
I don't know if I should look for it.
Okay, it seems like the app wants me to go with the power one, which is fine.
Oh, it's green.
It's cute.
Pay for power.
Yes.
I would love to do that.
Sweet.
It looks like it's been paid.
Now, I'm just going to see if I can confirm it.
Or if I can leave the screen.
That would also be fine.
I don't know if I'm allowed to do that.
Oh, I'm lost to my inside.
That's fun.
Can I go home from there?
No.
Cool.
I'm kind of stuck in this domain, I think.
Okay, cool.
So you've removed the...
Oh, there I go.
Sweet.
So you removed it, and then you were stuck on what screen?
Sorry?
I was stuck on the pay screen, so this screen.
Right.
Because I think for this, because the colours are kind of darker, I assumed it was blurred
out or in the background, so I didn't realise I could actually still interact with this
screen.
Okay.
That makes sense.
I think I would have been looking for a back button or something.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
Awesome.
Cool.
And if you just go back to the dashboard.
Awesome.
Cool.
I'm going to go back to past expenses from the previous week and find out who paid for
one of them.
Okay.
So I'm thinking about past expenses.
The first thing I look at is an expenses tab.
I'm going to go to that.
I'm looking at the past week.
That probably includes today as well.
So there's all these three.
Back to expenses?
Yeah.
Past week, played the garbage.
Paid for some food.
Paid for some rent.
Is there anything else?
No.
That's all.
Cool.
And task four is validate the insights feature for the rent category and ensure that you
can see the data for it.
So you're just viewing the rent category insights, specifically for rent.
Okay.
Oh, insights.
All right.
So insights being the bottom here.
And I want to look at the rent category.
So I'm going to click on rent.
See what happens.
Oh, I see it.
I see today I paid 50.
If I press on monthly, I pay 50 every week.
Which makes a lot of sense.
That's how rent works.
Sweet.
Awesome.
Task five, test the customization options for the display and accessibility.
Okay.
Yeah.
So if I'm thinking about accessibility, I'm always going to go here.
I see settings.
That's good.
Display settings.
It probably would be in display settings, I would guess.
Oh, yeah.
Accessibility.
High contrast and colorblind friendly.
Let me try high contrast.
Nice.
Dark mode.
I like it.
Colorblind friendly.
Oh, yeah.
So it's all the same color.
Or it's the same color scheme.
So there's people with color.
Cool.
Is there anything else?
Just test the light dark mode.
Make sure that works.
Yeah.
Dark mode seems to work.
Follow system.
Cool.
Easy.
And if you just go back to default.
That's okay.
Just on the display settings.
Sorry.
Higher.
Yeah.
That's all good.
Sweet.
Cool.
And just go back to the dashboard.
Perfect.
Cool.
Task six, test the help and support functionality.
So first go to the frequently answered questions and look at that.
And then try and submit a help request.
Okay.
I'm going to go to this menu again.
It's kind of always my default if I think about settings and stuff.
Help and support's right there.
So I'm going to go there.
I'm not allowed to click on it.
Cool.
Okay.
If we could continue by just go to app settings.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Help and support.
So I want to look at frequently asked questions first.
The purpose of it.
Just that one.
That's all good.
And then I want to submit a help request.
Contact support.
And just input there.
Do an email.
And my deep concern.
And I can send it.
Nice.
Okay, cool.
Awesome.
And any general thoughts on any of the tasks?
I thought they were pretty good.
I'm pretty impressed with what you actually put together and the time we were given.
I like the separation of who you have to pay and your upcoming payments.
I do think it's a lot for one app to do.
I think more often apps would work for either one thing or the other.
So I think it could be a little confusing to have so much functionality in one thing.
But if you were an experienced user and you figured out how to use it, it would be awesome.
Cool.
And any big difficulties with any of the tasks?
I don't think so.
I think probably the main thing would just be with the help thing, not being able to
access it there.
But I assume if it was a real prototype, that wouldn't be an issue.
Cool.
Awesome.
Sweet.
And that's it for now.
Awesome.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Hell yeah.